make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and i
want to try something a little bit
different a lot of you guys have asked
me to cover mortal kombat comics and
with the trailer for the movie coming
out i figure we might as well go ahead
and give it a shot
what we're going to do here is we're
going to do an excerpt from the mortal
kombat comics we're going to do the
origin of scorpion we're going to kind
of kick things off with this and it's
really more of just a test to see
whether or not you know you guys are
interested
in this kind of thing uh because
scorpion i feel like probably one of
probably the single most popular
character
in all of mortal kombat if i'm being
honest with you guys i mean luke hang i
think is a close second but when anybody
is ever talking about mortal kombat when
they think of the game the first person
they think of is usually scorpion
sometimes shang tsung sometimes sub-zero
right but it really just kind of depends
so what we end up having here in this
this bit of a segment again this is
gonna be a pretty short video what we
end up having here
is basically a kind of conversation
taking place in the himalayas between
hanzo hisashi who's which is his real
name but you guys know him as scorpion
and takeda now i could be wrong maybe
it's pronounced something like taquita
i'm not 100 sure but takeda sounds like
it's the correct pronunciation but
decayed is basically the ward of hanzo
hisashi not really his son
not his biological son uh he actually
the the father of takeda is a main
character in the story and depending on
whether or not you guys are interested
we'll cover it from beginning to end
because it's not super lengthy it's not
it's not a super lengthy mortal kombat
comic book series it's like 36 issues
but the conversation
starts going in the direction of an
ability that takeda had seen
hanzo use or seen scorpion use which was
the ability to control hellfire and
initially takeda thinks it's like a
style of martial art right it just takes
time and mastery to be able to pull it
off but the reality is is hanzo
basically tells him it's not a style
right it's not some kind of a style he
mastered over time that is actually his
curse and so this is when we jump into
the origin of scorpion now one thing to
understand the origin as is given to us
here
is by no means an exceedingly in-depth
origin of scorpion right it's not like
it's
colossal and exceedingly nuanced it's
more of just kind of broad strokes but
what we're basically told is at some
point
in the past hanzo's family and his clan
the shirairu are basically killed by
sub-zero now one of the things the
origin doesn't really give us here is
what's actually going on right so we can
kind of
we'll sort of give you guys the real
depiction of what truly happened
uh once we get done with this little bit
right but when hanzo hisashi was
basically executed by
by sub-zero by literally having his head
ripped off of his body the last thing he
saw was his wife and child
basically frozen to death by sub-zero
losing his family and the result is that
he died but his soul
suddenly just kind of kept on going he
was so filled with vengeance and rage
that he never actually passed on
instead somebody basically grabbed him
and then
kind of brought him back even if only
for a momentary period in time
and this of course takes place in the
nether realm which is more or less
mortal kombat's version of hell
but what you end up having is him
basically being brought back by a guy
named quan chi
now quan chi was not part of the
original mortal kombat line
of video games right mortal kombat 1 2
and 3. he wasn't introduced until much
later but what had happened is they had
retroactively
brought his character in right so what
they basically said is that quan chi
has always been in the world of mortal
kombat we just didn't see him until
recently but he's a sorcerer and an
exceedingly powerful one who's right up
there with
with uh shang tsung now the reason why
you see so much of shang tsung in mortal
kombat to kind of step aside for a
second the reason why you see him so
much is because he's the emperor's
favorite sorcerer and so because of that
he's the guy that usually always gets
the attention
quan chi is usually always vying to
subvert the the authority of of shang
tsung
and even to a greater extent actually
lead to the downfall of shao khan and
ultimately have him replaced or or
really uh lead to the rise of chinook
one of the one of the fallen elder gods
or the only real fallen elder god that's
out there right but he is by all
standards of measurement a guy who's
working against both shang tsung
and xiao kant but him resurrecting uh
scorpion came by way of a bit of
curiosity in the sense that he realized
that the the hellfire within the realm
of the nether realm couldn't hurt
uh hanzo hasashi because he was just so
filled with with anger and vengeance
with quan chi realized he could use for
his own
ends and so what he ended up doing was
basically summoning hanzo hisashi away
from his shackles and then
imbuing him with the power of hellfire
and basically pointing him in the
direction of saying like you know we can
get you i can help you get revenge on
the people who murdered your family i
can help you achieve that goal and so
using his hellfire and then showing up
in the original mortal kombat tournament
he was just
facing off against various people and
then ultimately managed to kill bihan
also known as
sub-zero the problem that hanzo hisashi
had with all this though
is that no matter how much vengeance or
no matter how many people he killed that
this fire kind of kept burning inside of
him
all the time he was constantly driven by
like rage
and anger and hatred over his own over
the loss of his own individual family
that's what that's one of the reasons
why
scorpion has really kind of remained as
a mainstay and an exceedingly popular
character
in mortal kombat one because of the fact
that his fatalities that he just like
sets you on fire which is i mean it's
not cool to set people on fire but in
the game it is right the game is awesome
plus he's just kind of a hallmark
character right he's one of the og
characters that's been around for a long
long time and so there's a kind of
grandfathered concept that goes in with
this character like yeah man he's been
around forever and absolutely love him
uh
but it's also because he's exceedingly
tragic this is a guy who's lost
everything once his origin became more
concrete once it was expanded beyond its
original
depiction as it was given to us as
mortal kombat fans then it turned out he
was an exceedingly tragic character he
was a guy who lost everything
and was just governed by vengeance and
rage and anger right that's the the
things that controlled his life which
for a lot of people was relatable right
a lot of people could relate to that
idea just kind of having their life
dominated by vengeance and
anger and so as a result of that
ultimately even after his life was
restored after
he was removed from being a kind of
undead spectre and being brought back to
life in a
in the the true and proper way he still
had all that anger that governed him
right all that anger that controlled him
now
over time he was able to basically
curtail that right and he was able to
bring his anger and his rage back under
control
and go back to being you know having
some semblance of a normal or at least a
relatively normal life but whenever it
is that he uses his hellfire his curse
is that if he does it for too long he'll
revert back into his his almost
maddening state right just kind of the
way that he used to be and so that's why
he always has to keep that part of his
life
completely in check but jumping back to
what we were talking about before
the reality is that scorpion's family
was not killed by sub-zero in the lin
kuei clan instead it was done by quan
chi
like quan chi was the one who basically
manipulated all that stuff in order to
bring scorpion under his control and use
him for his own ends and so the reality
is that when scorpion killed sub-zero he
in effect killed the wrong guy
and that's one of the things that he
kind of came to realize over time now of
course it never really
changed it's not like he was like oh you
know and made made you know amends or
anything at least not that i'm aware of
uh but that's kind of the nature of
scorpion's origin that's
the the nature of the character that we
know he's a guy that lost everything
only to find out that he was tricked
into believing it was the wrong man and
then killed the wrong man and then in
turn when he was brought back by quan
chi who was the one that actually did it
he was in the service of quan chi until
he was ultimately freed and now he's
been trying to live some measure of a
normal life ever since right i mean when
i say normal i mean normal within the
realm of mortal kombat and the character
of scorpion right so you know
fighting and killing people that kind of
a thing but always trying to keep that
that
that darker version of himself under
control right so uh with that being said
guys i know again this is a pretty short
video but we're gonna go ahead and bring
this to an end if you guys want to see
more mortal kombat
stuff let me know down in the comment
section i would love to hear your all's
responses and to see what you all think
uh if you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob corp if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you